مئات ممن دخلوا المستشفى الاهل المعمدان
في غزه اما مرضى او جرحى او نازحون
سيغادرون اشلاء وجثث قرار الخروج الى
القبر وقعه جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بغرا
قاتله ومدمره على اهداف مدنيه حاله من
الذعر والهلع سادت ساحه ومبنى المستشفى
الذي يفترض وبموجب القوانين والاعراف
الدوليه في مناطق النزاعات ان استهداف فه
انتهاك يرقى الى جريمه حرب لجت بعض
العائلات الى ساحته للبقاء بالقرب من
مرضاهم او جرحاهم واخرون بحثا عن ماوى بعد
ان حولت الغارات بيوتهم الى ركام فوجدوا
انفسهم في ليل غزه المظلم والمؤلم يبحثون
عن جثه ابن او بنت او اب او
ام اغلب الصور قويه وصادمه يتعذر بثها
استمر القصف الاسرائيلي خلال ساعات الليل
والنهار بلا هواده مخلفا في كل مره شهداء
ومصابين اغلبهم اطفال ونساء وشيوخ حتى
مدارس الانرو التابعه للامم المتحده لم
تسلم من ضربات جيش الاحتلال لا محرمات ولا
خطوط حمر ولا خشيه من انتهاك القانون
الدولي الانساني من سيحاسب اسرائيل التي
يبارك الغرب قولا وفعلا ما هي فاعله وست
بغزه واهلها العزل هنا الصور حقيقيه
وبمليون كلمه وهذه اثار الانتهاك غير
الاخير للاحتلال في المدرسه الواقعه في
مخيم المغازي للاجئين استشهد وفق الاونر
وما لا يقل عن سته فلسطينيين وصفت الوكاله
ما حدث بالامر الشائن وبانه يظهر مره اخرى
استخفافا صارخا بحياه
المدنيين غارات كثيفه وعشرات الشهداء
والمصابين في عده مناطق من القطاع خلال
نهار الثلاثاء الدام عزاء وحداد مفتوحان
في خان يونس ورفح نفس الوجع والاضرار
البشريه والماديه في مخيم البريج وسط
القطاع واحياء في مدينه غزه منها حي
الزيتون مساحات شاسعه تحولت الى مقابر قد
لا تكون كافيه امام عدد الشهداء المتزايد
بشكل مخيف نداءه الاستغاثه لوقف اله الحرب
الاسرائيليه يقابلها طوفان الدعم الغربي
غير المشروط لاسرائيل وما ترتكبه في غزه
وساكنيها كل هذا والاجتياح البري الذي تعد
له العده لم يبدا بعد العالم في اختبار
حرب غزه الدائره سقطت عنه اقنعه اخرى وظهر
تجذر ازدواجيه المعايير لدى حكومه تصف نفس
بانها جزء من العالم الحر
المتقدم